[Musique]
j'ai sauvé ma vie grâce à mon assiette
mais j'en ai d'aujourd'hui n'ont rien à
voir avec celle d'hier
hier je ne pouvais pas marcher plus de
20 minutes
j'avais des migraines en permanence et
je ne dormais pas de la tête aux pieds
en passant par le ventre je souffrais
depuis que j'ai changer d'alimentation
je cours je dors comme un bébé et je
fais le championnat de france en
équitation
pourtant rien ne présageait d'un tel
avenir il y a 6 ans j'ai été
diagnostiqué d'une endométriose c'est
une maladie qui touche une femme sur dix
en âge de procréer concrètement ce sont
des nodules qui se propage dans le corps
tout le tous les mois et est grossiste
tous les mois quand j'ai été
diagnostiquée j'étais au stade 5 le plus
avancé
on a constaté des masses de nodules qui
collait mes organes notamment l'intestin
la vessie
on m'a donc opérer on m'a retiré 12 cm
de nodules après l'intervention et même
avant j'avais aussi de nombreux
symptômes quotidien pendant 42 ans
je ne savais pas ce que c'était dormir
je me réveillais trois à cinq fois par
nuit pendant 25 ans j'ai eu des
migraines toutes les semaines à droite à
gauche ça pouvait durer trois jours
j'avais des nausées et à force ça me
rendait agressif
c'était comme si j'étais à côté d'une
autoroute et que je voulais écouter de
la musique ça me demandait une énergie
folle
pendant cinq ans on a infiltré la
cheville gauche mon rhumatologue
m'interdisait de marché plus de 20
minutes
évidemment je ne pouvais plus courir et
fini les chaussures à talons quand je
mangeais mon ventre gonflé j'avais mal
au ventre j'avais des somnolences depuis
tout petit j'ai été sujette à des
problèmes de constipation ça pouvait
durer plus d'une semaine à tel point que
le changement de lieu accentuer ce
problème du coup le week-end les
vacances je n'arrivais plus à profiter
de mes proches
cette vie c'était la mienne je la
croyais normal en fait je me voyais pas
vivre autrement mon ostéopathe qui me
connaissaient avec mes douleurs et qui
était au courant de mon opération a vu
qu'un an après je continue à souffrir
du coup il m'a proposé d'aller
rencontrer un médecin spécialisé en
nutrition
j'avais rien à perdre je suis aller le
consulter
j'ai eu une chance incroyable j'ai
rencontré mon docteur house à moi c'est
un médecin généraliste qui est diplômé
de médecine chinoise qui s'est
spécialisée depuis 25 ans en biologie
nutritionnels en particulier les
hypersensibilités alimentaire il m'a
fait faire des tests
l'intoxication des organes l'état des
neurotransmetteurs la carence des
oligo-éléments les intolérances
alimentaires et aussi la candidose la
candidose c'est une prolifération
anormale d'un champignon que nous avons
tous dans l'intestin
le candidat albi quand il se nourrit de
sucre fermenté que nous produisons et si
nous en produisons trop
il va en fait se multiplier de façon
anormale et créer une information qui
peut être majeur le bilan mara tu étais
très intoxiqué montaut dingue très bas
mais neurotransmetteur était
complètement déréglé notamment la
dopamine et la sérotonine la sérotonine
on appelle l'hormone du bonheur et on la
produit à 95% dans notre vente
également les intolérances alimentaires
ont été confirmés et effectivement
j'avais une candidose la solution de mon
docteur house globalement l'éviction
alimentaire j'ai retiré 10 aliments de
mon alimentation
le gluten et les les animaux me sont
interdits à vie parce qu'ils me rendent
malade en particulier le gluten la
vanille la banane l'ananas le sulfite
les jeux les tolère pas très bien et en
fonction mon stress et ma fatigue qui
peuvent provoquer des réactions
physiologiques cutanée ballonnements
voir somnolence pour la candidose il
faut arrêter pendant un certain temps
en plus du gluten et l'ailé le soja tout
et levures et tous les sucres raffinés
et naturel aujourd'hui j'ai moins besoin
de mon docteur house non seulement je
vais mieux
j'ai retrouvé la santé mais en plus j'ai
découvert des résultats inattendus
souvent me pose la question est ce que
tu te fais plaisir en mangeant
aujourd'hui est en fait je réponds avant
je croyais me faire plaisir mais c'est
aujourd'hui que je me fais plaisir en
mangeant
j'ai retrouvé le goût naturel dans mon
palais mais papy s'éclate en fait elles
font leur job
le premier job c'est qu'elle vous créer
une émotion intense ou gustatives et
après elle prépare la digestion
donc du coup j'ai un plaisir durable ma
coiffeuse à ne revient pas on se connaît
depuis longtemps
elle m'a connu avec des cheveux très
affaiblie elle a constaté aujourd'hui
qu'il pousse est non seulement très vite
mais qui se régénérer du coup ils
s'éclatent et moi je me fais plaisir les
faire pousser
les ongles c'est pareil c'est comme les
cheveux ils sont très en forme
avant ils se cassaient tout le temps il
se dédoubler et en fait aujourd'hui
pourtant je suis pas plus soigneuse qui
hier ils sont hyper résistant
j'ai jamais connu ça mon entourage quand
j'ai commencé à changer d'alimentation
me disait tu as l'air en forme mais pas
j'ai maigri en fait ils voyaient dans
mon visage que j'étais à nouveau
épanouie le plus impressionnant ce avec
le sport j'ai toujours été sportif
j'adore ça et malgré mes problèmes de
santé j'ai continué à le faire pourtant
j'ai payé le prix cher
j'avais des muscles qui me faisait très
très mal et j'avais un rythme cardiaque
perturbé après l'effort m'est avis avec
qui je pars au ski tous les ans constate
depuis quatre ans que je vais plus vite
j'ai plus de technique et j'ai plus
confiance sur la pente
je marche en endurance et je fais huit
kilomètres huit kilomètres et demi un
tapis roulant
j'adore nager depuis longtemps mon
kilomètres quand j'ai l'occasion de
brasse et crawl
après je me sens super bien mais surtout
j'ai pu reprendre mon sport de passion
l'équitation
je monte un cheval de 8 ans qui pèse 650
kg qui mesure 1 m 75
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
de cavaliers un cheval et physique
on prépare ensemble championnat de
france en saut et en dressage
on s'amuse bien il n'y a pas un moment
où je ne partage pas mon histoire
en fait dès qu'il ya un repas c'est
l'occasion d'une discussion autour de
l'alimentation au boulot dans la vie
privée au resto au sport je suis connu
comme madame lunch box
sauf si évidemment la restauration c'est
réponde à mes besoins alimentaires
également je suis réputé en compétition
de venir avec mes collation pour être en
énergie des graines des noix d'amandes
du chocolat noir des fruits il ya des
cavaliers même qui viennent me voir en
disant tu pourrais me dire un peu ce que
je peux faire en alimentation pour
améliorer mes performances
j'ai aussi des praticiens qui m'envoient
certains de leurs patients pour échanger
avec eux parce qu'il faut savoir que la
démarche de changer d'alimentation peut
être parfois compliqué non seulement on
doit se réorganiser dans la journée on a
quand même à peu près trois repas
réorganiser mais en fait le plus
compliqué c'est la relation avec son
environnement
celui-ci souvent va essayer de vous
dissuader et il faut savoir que vos
proches peuvent être les plus durs voilà
je vous ai raconté mon histoire
personnelle mais en fait j'ai aussi
envie d'aller voir les perdre et autres
les personnes pour savoir un peu
ce qui se passait du coup j'ai fait un
sondage auprès de 200 salariés et 150
étudiants parmi les salariés que j'ai
rencontré j'en ai un sur quatre qui
m'annonce spontanément une pathologies
digestives
j'en ai un sur trois qui me parlent
d'intolérance ou 10 persan et visible sa
sensibilité alimentaire ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces gens sont
diagnostiqués ou pas ça veut dire qu'il
ya des personnes qui savent
concrètement qui a des ingrédients
qu'ils en font mal parmi les étudiants
j'en ai huit sur dix qui partent le
ventre vide 1 sur 7 me parle d'
addiction au sucre et 1 sur 2 me parle
de stress que ce soit des hommes et des
femmes d'ailleurs et si l'alimentation
pouvait réduire tout ça ce qui est
génial dans le changement alimentaire
c'est que la moindre petite chose que
vous changez le bénéfice est très rapide
ici vous évoluez dans votre amélioration
d'alimentation vous en avez sous le pied
c'est absolument génial vous souvenez de
cette autoroute à côté de laquelle
j'étais où j'essaye d'écouter de la
musique
aujourd'hui je ne fournit plus d'efforts
je ne pond plus 90% de mon énergie pour
faire des choses normales dormir marché
avoir la tête légère
est ce que mon changement alimentaire a
résolu mon problème d'armes de me
trilles aux noms je continue à prendre
un médicament tous les jours est ce que
mon changement alimentaire un
radicalement changé ma vie endométriose
ou pas d'ailleurs clairement oui je
raconte mon histoire comme je le fais
avec vous parce que je veux vous passer
un message simple personne ne peut dire
que l'alimentation n'a pas un impact sur
le corps l'alimentation c'est la santé
c'est plus qu'une formule tendance c'est
vraiment une réalité
et si la manière dont nous mangeons
pouvait être regardé autrement je n'ai
plus qu'à vous souhaiter bon appétit
merci